bonjour estelle une réunion est donc
prévue entre le ministre de l'intérieur
de la justice et de l'éducation
nationale à la mi-journée
quelle est la teneur de cette rencontre
eh bien écoutez à magali et avait
préféré différents à département est
d'ile-de-france ont tout aussi été
conviés à cette réunion ainsi que les
recteurs d'académie et les procureurs de
la république de paris de bobigny ou
encore de avec créteil objectif élaborer
un plan pour mettre un terme aux
violences entre bandes des risques qui
ont défrayé la chronique la semaine
dernière avec la mort de deux
adolescents lundi c'est une jeune fille
de 14 ans qui a succombé après avoir été
poignardé le
c'est un jeune de 13 ans qui est décédé
dans une bagarre des faits qui se sont
tous de dérouler dans l'essonne sachez
que selon le figaro 357 affrontements
entre bandes rivales ont eu lieu en
france en 2020 dont 80 % en
ile-de-france
estelle face aux problèmes le ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin a fait
savoir qu'à renforts de policiers
étaient attendus dans l'essonne et il
demande aux préfets de rupture réactiver
le plan de lutte contre les violences en
bandes
exactement olivier selon les
informations du jdd gérald permanent
aurait envoyé le 26 février
directives aux préfets il leur demande
un état des lieux de la violence en
bande dans chaque département origine
des violences h des individus ou encore
l'utilisation non à des réseaux sociaux
par exemple le ministre de l'intérieur
qui souhaite aussi que la surveillance
de ces derniers soient renforcés car
pour gérald darmanin le mimétisme des
réseaux sociaux je cite ainsi à que les
messageries à crypter jouent des rôles
importants dans ces violences s'est en
tout cas est ce qu'il a déclaré lors de
son déplacement dans l'essonne la
semaine dernière gérald darmanin à qui
vous l'avez dit a aussi demandé au
préfet de réactiver le plan de lutte
contre les bandes sachez que ce plan a
été créé en 2010 et hiller il avait
notamment permis la création de cellules
dans une quête dédié au phénomène merci
beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions on va suivre avec nous
évidemment cette réunion donc entre les
préfets et les différents ministres
concernés et se télécharge en direct de
la place beauvau à paris